tropical storm harvey is a lead once
again hammering the gulf coast after
making landfall for a second time severe
flash flooding hit Beaumont and Port
Arthur Texas this morning after hours of
heavy rain the local sheriff says port
author is cut off is cut off by flooding
and people there are now going into what
he calls survival mode East Texas and
Louisiana are now seeing the worst of
harvey Houston's actually seeing some
Sun today after days of record rainfall
but Louisiana may see another six to
eight inches of rain over the next two
days we begin our coverage this morning
with Michelle Miller who was along the
Louisiana Texas border she's east of
Beaumont there Orange Texas Michelle
good morning good morning in Orange
Texas it's about 23 miles east if we're
harvey made landfall overnight we should
note that this is i 10 the service road
folks staging they're bringing their
boats we've seen all kinds flat-bottomed
boats airboats hoping to make rescues
because this is a foot and a half of
water this service road a virtual bayou
and that's mainly because when the storm
came ashore it did so at high tide 24
inches of rain over a 24 hour period
just gave me for the perfect one-two
punch further down in Port Arthur is
really treacherous and folks are on
social media simply begging for help it
was brutal overnight there every highway
is closed so we can't get out of
Port Arthur Texas is inundated as Harvey
made landfall and lingered overnight
search and rescue operations were
suspended at nightfall because the
conditions were simply too dangerous on
social media people reported fires like
this one burning unchecked at this
apartment building those who dare to
drive encountered heavy rain and intense
wind gusts mayor Derrick Freeman says an
estimated 20,000 homes have water in
them
we have water all across the city five
six feet deep in some places this is a
very massive critical type situation
that we're under and we're trying to get
it handled
[Music]
people who evacuated to the city's Civic
Center face a deluge everybody needs to
start kind of going in that survival
mode and start trying to get yourself to
higher elevations get on your on your
roof you may sit up there and get wet by
the rain but you're gonna not drowned it
is still sitting over us as we speak
Darla Martinez says Samaritan saved her
mother 80 year-old Phyllis Martinez from
her Jefferson County home as the water
rose overnight when I seen him carrying
her in in his arm suggest I had my phone
in my hand and I just snapped the
picture because I just wanted I wanted
to thank the young men we still don't
know if those people were able to be
moved out of the Civic Center to another
location we do know that Port Arthur is
home to the largest oil refinery in the
country motiva announced this morning
that they are shutting down its
operations as soon as these floodwaters
abate they say they'll be back up and
running we'll keep tracking that Thank
You Michelle